so today we're going to do another day
on Aristotle's ethics and if this were
an ethics class we'd spend about three
weeks on it we don't have that luxury in
an intro class because this is you know
a survey we we look at a lot of stuff
and we we don't go that deep into it but
we want to introduce you to a lot of
things now this chapter is not just
about ethics though for this book book 3
this also has to do with metaphysics
because it has to do with responsibility
human responsibility so that means that
it has to do with the structure of human
beings the way that we're put together
there are some things that we might say
or there are some views which might hold
that everything that a human being does
is totally free there's other views that
say that everything that a human being
does is totally determined it's not
actually up to them and these are
metaphysical views these aren't just
ethical views we're going to be mainly
with your ethical implications but I
want you to keep that in mind over the
course this message is we're going to
approach this topic again we're going to
look at whether you actually do have
what we call free will how many of you
just sort of take a poll how many do you
think that you have some degree free
well either is there anybody here who
thinks that you don't that everything
you do is determined well there's kind
of a puzzle right actually two puzzles
are there any people you think don't
have to be well on some level you know
if you ever say something like well that
person couldn't have chosen otherwise
than to be what they are then you're
you're in effect denying them free will
right what is this free will that we're
thinking of them that's kind of fuzzy
isn't it I mean if we all do think that
we have all of you do I think I've got
well what exactly is it that's a little
bit harder to say is sort of like time
st. Augustine somebody that we're not
going to read this semester I wish you
actually we had the time to he talks
about time he says you know when nobody
asked me what time is I think I know
exactly what it is i'm working with the
perfect we find as soon as you ask me
what it is i realized i have no idea
what I'm talking about I think it's very
similar with free will somebody who you
are going to read this semester pretty
soon Saint Anselm says that free will is
really a very mysterious and murky thing
and it requires learning about a lot of
other things in order to figure out what
pretty well this Aristotle's not going
to go quite as deep into his analysis of
it but these are very complex
metaphysical issues this also ties in
with what we call philosophical
anthropology or sometimes you call it
the metaphysics of the human person
again because it has to do with these
things fundamental issues we're going to
get from an ethical perspective so I
want you to think about these questions
that I put on the board and I would like
you to think you need to write them down
or just have them in mind and I want you
to think a little bit of values what do
we hold people responsible for think
about a few things that we generally
hold people responsible maybe not but
generally right and then think about
another thing though the flip side of
that what don't we hold people
responsible in their actions some have
some actions we hold people completely
responsible for other actions that they
actually do we don't hold them
responsible for what are you know some
some examples of that then you can ask
another question what should we hope
people
maybe we don't actually have the right
answers in all the time when we're doing
this maybe we don't hold people
responsible for some things that we
actually should hold them responsible
for as a society or maybe the opposite
maybe we hold people responsible for
things that are really out of their
control I'll give you some some examples
of that I don't I don't actually need
you necessarily to come up with these
it'll be enough if you can come up with
these and then we'll talk in class about
this last question one of the the people
who do if you take my ethics class
you'll read Jeremy Bentham he was a
great legal reformer and the British
legal code at the time was kind of harsh
almost barbaric you know you can commit
a very small crime and get a really huge
penalty there are lots of capital crimes
of course this was not that unusual most
of the legal codes at that time were
like that and he thought that a lot of
people were being held responsible for
things and being punished severely for
things that really they had no control
over you know stealing this is a classic
dilemma you have children you have no
way of getting a job no way of getting
money your children are starving to you
steal bread to feed them well you know
in England at the time the Bentham was
writing if you did steal that Fred you
can get yourself in a lot of trouble and
now what would happen in our society
they would say don't steal that breath
that's a misdemeanor maybe if you were
in California and three strikes and
you're out you've already done two
felony offenses you getting a lot of
trouble but for the most part we're
pretty media than that anyone they
weren't you know that was a
life-and-death daily question for a lot
of people so you know should we hold
somebody responsible for stealing bread
in a situation like that
or think about addiction um yes you
actually are addicted to something with
certain types of addiction it can remove
your capacity for free choice think
about it you know if you are hooked on
any of the really big hard drugs like
cocaine or crack or meth or heroin or
heroin primitives you know various
opiates I suppose we could add oxycontin
to that and a few other drugs as well if
you're addicted to any of those sorts of
things you have to feed that addiction
and you will do pretty much anything you
need to feed that addiction right that's
why we have skits about you know
crackheads who will do just about
anything possible refute that addiction
thing about Dave Chappelle right its
character the Kraken why why does it
actually at home because wonder why
could you yeah that's right why why
should you actually make a character
like that because people can look at
that say yeah people who are addicted to
this or this they are less responsible
for their actions so are there cases
where people are treated as not being
responsible but they should be treated
this responsible there might be cases
like that right so let's look at some of
your answers this what are some things
that we hold people responsible for ya
what they say okay good what they say
alright what they say so if you if you
blurt out somebody secret now you did
something wrong right if you call
somebody a bad name you know you were
responsible for that yeah
okay the three others do we always do
that what if what if somebody has a mean
streak to them do we sometimes excuse
them and say yeah you can't really take
its heart the fact that that person trip
to anybody ever say anything like the
item I'm not asked about you personally
but have you ever seen people who excuse
other people on the basis of their
character they're just kind of
thoughtless so we don't always hold
people responsible for everything how we
treat others right and what else do we
have what other kinds of things to be
typically I'm in a hole all of you
responsible for your performance on damn
right test it I'm not going to hold one
person responsible for somebody else's
performance I'm not going to like say ok
mr. Kuhn is the only student who's going
to matter the class whatever your grade
he gets everybody else gets that great
that would be crazy right yeah he'd be
studying a lot that right because all of
you would be on his case study hard that
could be kind of an interesting thing to
do to a class when I say interesting i
don't mean i could actually do it myself
but i'm sure some somebody's trying what
else what else do we hold people
responsible for colonization
decisions okay so now this is kind of
interesting you can decide to do
something and that precedes the actual
action doesn't like you can I can decide
I decided earlier today that I'm going
to a lecture later on tonight after this
this class I'm going to stick around
here at marys or I been since eight
o'clock and go hear somebody talk about
philosophy you know those reasons why
and I'm responsible for choosing that I
haven't got done in have I I could
change my mind later and not do it or
something to come along and prevent me
from doing like maybe I'm going up the
stairs and I slip and fall and break my
life well I'm not going to the lecture
that I'm going to the hospital but the
fact that I decided it that's still
there isn't it so sometimes the decision
sometimes the decision in the action on
tried the same thing you know somebody's
pushing you and you do you react and you
pop up in the nose alright hopefully
this isn't happening very often right
but these things do happen that's a case
of somebody deciding and acting at the
same time but a lot of our decisions we
make and then the action will happen or
not later on and we do hold people
responsible for that if you choose the
right thing but you're not able to bring
it off we still give you the credit for
it quite often don't you choose the
wrong thing and it doesn't it doesn't
come off successfully like here's your
good example let's say all of you have
good friends right one form or another
once they you have some good friends are
the same sex as you because this
assuming that that sort of the
heterosexual paranoid right
go show every single possible
contingency just to make it work for
every every sexual orientation so we'll
stick with you know many women say man
you have you know male best friends that
might steal their their problem or women
have women best friends you might steal
their boyfriend if you were best friend
it actually has the intention and makes
the decision let's say they write it
down to their diary or something I'm
going to steal your your boyfriend and
girlfriend let's say it doesn't work
let's say your boyfriend and girlfriend
his guy food character and says I'm not
gonna lie you know this sort of thing to
happen but you find out about it later
on you're going to hold that person
responsible why don't you yeah cuz well
it didn't work so don't harm no foul
alright I hope not it's not that would
be loved your very forgiving but maybe a
little imprudent so you know we got
decisions anything else you
what else can you think of that we do
old people respond what else did you
guys right now oh that's very
interesting that's why parents will
often get quite up tight right thickness
be even you're embarrassing me in public
I remember my mom saying stuff like that
yeah if something's a bad kid quite
often will say yeah look at that
person's awful parenting skills but it
actually I used to show this one of my
classes there's actually a kind of look
that shows this kid and he's in a
grocery store he is just throwing a
tantrum you don't know it's a condom ban
until the very end of the thing you see
this kid going nuts and everybody around
them you know the staff his eyes just
a-rolling everybody around is kind of
expressing disdain for this this awful
dad who can't control his kit than the
size of condoms that's the message of
that but it could just be hey that guy's
a jerk that's why it's kids a jerk or
you know could go the other way why do
parents want you to excel and succeed
they may I hope that all you actually do
the parents that want it for your own
sake because they love you and care
about you but you know there are some
parents who want their kids to succeed
why yeah makes them it makes them look
at it and reflects on them as parents
and the only reason why would it would
think that is because we think that
parents actually do
some influence on their children if
children and parents totally random
unconnected it doesn't make any sense to
hold parents responsible husband we even
do this legally I mean if your kid as
you get in enough trouble in the right
cities or states your parents might have
to pay restitution or you know even do
do some some usually limited time
because of the things that you do
depends on the place where you are
though sometimes we'll just make you a
ward of the court and stuff what don't
make people responsible for I use the
example of vacation so let's let's leave
them what did what else don't we hold
people responsible for when it helps
their actions when do we tend to excuse
people say this like does that work but
maybe like for example when like the
economy of the country is not going like
in a good direction mm-hmm then like we
show will we tend to like ah said that
the president's or whoever's in charge
is that guilty person but not be society
oh okay yeah when when we shift the
blame for things to other people than we
don't hold people responsible we do this
yeah you're right sometimes with people
who are in charge below them did
anything wrong or had any role with just
this person's fall we do it the other
way to when excusing people will say
well the criminal really didn't you know
have any its societies from you know it
offered him all these these wonderful
things that he could get his hands on if
he stole killed
whatever and didn't get many
opportunities so we do stuff like that
anything else you can think of yet when
an accident occurs oh yeah when an
accident occurs sometimes we do hold
people like you've something like
malfunctions in your car and you hit
something else's car yeah ok that's a
good good example your brakes go up you
r ER at somebody they probably still
will like technically it's their fault I
guess but the primates use like the
moral aspect anything hell yeah
sometimes we do hold people responsible
you know when we talk about manslaughter
and I'm juggling axes and I shouldn't be
doing that in the nursery and the axe
falls and hits the kid and you know I
probably should not have been doing it
there but I didn't mean for it to happen
and notice even when we hold people
responsible to manslaughter charges
that's less than a murder charge jism
actually talked in another class today
about a guy who I knew when I was
teaching in prison who I really
sympathize with you is he in prison
because he had killed another and he got
murder one because he hunted the guy
down and kill them and you know we get
murder wanted people who premeditate now
why did he do it well the other man had
raped and killed his wife and this guy
was 20 years old and this is back in the
80s he could not count in all likelihood
on the justice system actually catching
and punishing the man
and killed his wife so you know he took
the law into his own hands went and
killed the other guy I consume them
thighs with its you know that's the sort
of case where we might actually like
Aristotle talk about maybe this guy was
actually less responsible maybe he was
being impelled by anger you know but the
prosecutor didn't see it that way
prosecutor said well you went and he
actually track the guy down so murder
one that was holding him completely
responsible right are there cases where
we don't hold somebody responsible
that's just accidents yeah you're right
there are those cases sometimes it's a
special subcase called by reason of
insanity somebody was not in their right
mind when they did the action so there's
a lot of wiggle room here ism Aristotle
wants to figure out okay when should we
actually say that somebody's responsible
one and one shouldn't wait let's think
about this now what do we do when we
hold people responsible for reactions
these are the sort of indices that tell
us there's responsibility at work so
what do we do when people are bad then
we hold them responsible punish them
yeah that's this one right punishment
could be corporal punishment you know
when you're a kid and you're misbehaving
in public and you're a parent comes up
behind me and gives you a pop in the
back of the head they're not just you
know doing that for fun I hope some do
but hopefully not that many they're
actually telling they're sending you a
message you should not behave like this
in public or maybe not at all right it
could be all sorts of other kinds of
questions so
it's all timeouts sometimes it seems a
little ineffective but you know
different styles I guess what are other
ways we punch before we put it in prison
we take away time from them we find them
money right you have to pay this amount
of money speeding tickets right how many
of that speaking takes before only want
to do wow these are very moment to live
shows what happens you know I mean you
know you get caught they give you a
citation they say you have to show up in
court or just pay this right now and
more pain in the mail & they're
punishing you they're saying you were
bad Oh what else do we do is that all we
did it punish people to rehabilitate
like issues then let's call that a
teacher sometimes we actually try to
teach people that we think I don't know
right wrong examples yeah very very good
I was I wasn't thinking of that but that
that fits in very well let's think about
celebrities that we think are doing the
wrong thing can we actually punish them
don't give them attention well they
don't care if one individual person
gives them attachment that could work
for other people right the practice of
shunning and Amish and Mennonite
communities is Ashley a form of
punishment it's a way to try to enforce
social conformity what else do we do
though who's a celebrity that you think
generally does the wrong thing anybody
Lindsay Lohan yeah she like shaped up at
all recently yeah I think she has I
don't know he's excited I am
I'm in order to news about it for a
while so I'm assuming she hasn't gotten
in trouble for a while she did get a lot
of trouble before right now when she was
let's say we're just talking about where
her when she was getting in trouble how
do people behave who didn't see Lindsay
lon couldn't actually Punisher
influencer what did they still do I say
bad things about right look at that you
know they pick whatever game you want so
we blame or criticize people who we
think are doing the wrong thing
realistically speaking can any of you
likely influence whoever happens to be
president at the time I mean it could
you know it could be like a movie kind
of thing where you know the letter
happens to reach their desk at just the
right time and it made it through
although you know tens of thousands of
letters that came that day that flutters
there and they open it up and you know
the president reason and says oh my
goodness I'm you know struck to the
heart by those angles you know criticism
of me for this policy that doesn't
usually happen does it what do we do it
we do still criticize people we say I
that person's doing the wrong thing or
what do we do if somebody's doing the
right thing we reward those right and
rewards finally come in just as many
varieties as punishment punishment right
we give them money we give them social
standing we sometimes we reward them by
not punishing them you know not
requiring them to do something we give
them nice things gift baskets you know
trophies things along those lines what
else would be the opposite of waiting or
criticizing let's say you like who the
presidents and what he
at the time you reach praise exactly I
suppose teaching you wouldn't teach them
to quit doing what they're doing you
maybe teach them to do it even better I
have to think more about that one that's
when I have and propose to me before is
an idea that is so these are the ways
and we tell whether we actually hold
people responsible arif it was the same
way in Aristotle's day we made every
society at every time there are some
actions that are praised in some actions
that are blamed their our summer awards
given out there some punishments given
up now if a person doesn't actually have
any control rewarding them or punishing
them is kind of a silly thing to do
isn't it still happens but if somebody
committed a crime and there was no
possibility for them to not commit that
crime maybe they shouldn't be punished
if somebody did something good but they
didn't mean to do anything they didn't
mean to do the good thing maybe we
shouldn't reward them know they couldn't
help her from doing that so when should
we hold people responsible what should
we actually hold them responsible for
not meeting to be resulting and we'll
look at this will def Aristotle talks
about the voluntary and the involuntary
and
let's use that as an example sneezing
okay great example happens all the time
yeah they have been more and more you
know now that's weather's turning is the
stealing of voluntary or involuntary
actions in volunteer hope nobody thinks
it's a voluntary action I mean it could
you know certain sense be a volunteer
yet there's a thing that you can
actually take to make yourself sneeze
type of tobacco is called snuff not the
stuff that you like put in here in your
mouth but little finely powdered tobacco
it was really big back at the
seventeenth and eighteenth and
nineteenth century coal miners still use
it because they see is to try to get all
the coal dust all of their lungs and
when I was over in Germany as a soldier
it was really popular we could get an
apricot or peppermint and all these
different sense the act of sneezing
itself those involuntary if something is
irritating here your sinuses that it
reaches a certain level you will sneeze
just like you know your breathing is not
actually voluntary for the most part
you're not even conscious of it and if
you try to you know hold your breath and
maybe some of you with your kids your
threaten to hold your breath driver why
didn't it work sooner or later your body
wants some air it makes you breathe
those are some examples of what
Aristotle which might fall compulsion in
this case it's not an external force
it's an internal force that's in you but
there's something in you that's making
that handle your emotions to a certain
extent are involuntary if I call you all
sorts of bad names on how do you feel
we're just out of the blue not like you
hit my car and be imaged it how do you
feel somebody just called you a whole
bunch of animators happy I love this
give me some more how do you feel anger
yeah that's one set of responses because
then why do you feel angry because you
feel that the person is doing the wrong
thing to you you might have other
responses you might feel you're not glad
sad glad mad you might be video upset
say happen all right go feel down are
you responsible for that feeling do you
have a choice of Aristotle extra cause
those passions meaning things that
happen to one things that are things
that are done to one you have some
control I mean how long you stay mad how
you will let the sadness affect you you
have control them in that aspect that
the sheer getting mad for the most part
you know aerosol says that things that
agent the person who's doing it or the
agent is the origin or any clause that's
when things are voluntary I decided to
walk across the room I am causing myself
to walk for us know if you had a gun and
you were doing something like in the
westerns viewer you know shooting at my
feet sing dance dr. sailor dance right
then that would be compulsion as I'm you
know jumping to avoid the bullets in
what respect it is still voluntary
because I could just I do have a choice
I could just sit there
the bullets hit my feet but I'd much
rather not do them I'd much rather dance
around and you know make you happy which
is why doing it the first place then
then get shot but that's much more
involuntary than voluntary if I grab one
of the aerosol uses this is an example
if I grabbed one of your hands that I
smack another person with it you didn't
actually smack the other person I smack
the other person and I used you as an
instrument for it well let's say I was
really big and strong and I picked you
up and I'm swinging here around like the
wrestlers do and I smack somebody else
with you again you would not be
responsible for that that would not be
your choice as a matter of fact probably
be screaming and you know trying to get
away while I was doing it right so if
compulsion can be something that makes
it involved here can you think of
anything else that would make it
involuntary well it's as Aristotle say
we're some other things that interfere
with the agent being in charge of what
they're doing
remember from the text ignorance very
good now Aristotle talks about a number
of things that you could be ignorant
sort of read this to you he says where
is that free absence well to determine
the nature and number of the things we
can be ignorant a man may be ignorant of
who he is that's pretty rare what he's
doing that's much more common what are
whom he's acting on sometimes also what
I what instrument he's doing it with and
to what end and how he's doing it he
says nobody could be ignorant of all of
these unless they were totally crazy so
we're not going to worry about totally
nuts people but most of these not so
much not knowing who you are you'd have
to be kind of crazy not to know who you
are as well right but the rest of these
would be to be ignorant of particular
things in that situation so let's look
at what you're doing he talks about the
example of telling a secret do you
always know that you're telling a secret
that you're divulging information that's
supposed to be kept from other people
when you do it you might think you're
just communicating something that
everybody knows people don't don't tell
me secrets and usually by the way
because I'm prone to this
I just I'm pretty straightforward so she
having deep secrets don't confine them
in me if you don't want other people to
know about them he's talking about some
guys in his time there was a sting
health mysteries you know was a
particular religion and actual is a
playwright he thought everybody knew
about it because I guess when he went to
the mysteries everybody knew was there
and so he divulged some of the secret
visuals blessing in his plays and then
people got angry and they said what the
hell are you doing you're giving away
our secrets any so I didn't think I was
doing that I thought I was just writing
a play can you think of other examples
where somebody thinks they're doing one
thing but they actually do another never
heard somebody on accident no none of
you have ever heard somebody physically
psychologically thanks boards maybe it's
easy to hurt people playing sports well
some search golf is it's been harder
than saying football I broke a kid's leg
in soccer that's not what I meant to do
actually we both met to do the same
thing which was to get to that ball
before the other guy did and we both
want up at the same time and you know we
saw the other guy coming so we've laid
into it as hard as we could we both
kicked it in exactly the same moment and
I ended up like flipping over and I
heard his leg crack now did I go out on
the soccer field saying I want to break
that guys like that's what I'm Annie did
I even do that in the moment what was I
trying to do yeah we have a different
description for the action I was trying
to kick the ball I didn't realize that
that was
effective all right neither did he I
mean it could have gone the other way I
could have broken my life and stuff I
don't know why is broken my didn't
probably a matter of physics anything
else like that that you can think of
were you intending one thing but you end
up doing another well let's look at some
of the other possibilities though what
room you're acting up sometimes we're
ignorant to this driving it actually
provide you some good examples of this
why did you hit the other car well you
didn't know that it was icy you didn't
know you were driving a car on an icy
road you thought that you were driving
on a road that was clean right that
could be a perfect example of that the
instrument that you're doing something
he is the example of sparring you know
fighting with weapons that are actually
supposed to be blunt back in the old
days they didn't you know have like PVC
and a practice swords to hit each other
with they actually use real swords but
they would blunt them or they'd make
them on wood and you might actually
think they can oh you're going to poke
somebody with with the thing that's
going to hurt him but not hurt him like
kill them just you know permanent and
turns out that somebody left the blunt
tip off the sword and do it the sword
goes through him and you say oh this
this didn't turn out the way I thought
it was good I was ignorant of one of the
particulars in the situation could we
think about anything like that in terms
of other things this means that you are
using
let's say that you don't realize that
you're well here's a good example a lot
of our apple juice apparently comes from
concentrating a lot of it is now coming
from China and Chinese products are not
actually the most safe I think you all
know this right lots of stuff winds up
in them and that probably shouldn't be
in there's not a lot of checking so all
of you let's assume your parents right
somewhere down the line I think most of
you are going to be parents who have
kids we're going to watch somebody
else's kids and one of the things that
you ought to do is make the kid a good
breakfast at least until they get old
enough to make themselves and maybe they
can start making you breakfast and what
do you know a good breakfast includes
every day such as cereal eggs juice I
can hold it off some coffee my family we
use a drink coffee really young you know
stuff to be good for you so you're
buying this apple juice and you're not
realizing that it actually has some
arsenic in it and you're giving it to
your kid day after day after day you
don't know that it doesn't say arsenic
on the label you're doing your due
diligence you're using an object that
you don't realize is damage that you
don't realize is corrupted in some way
there's lots of possible cases a lot of
the things that we do with our computers
I suppose since we don't actually know
the way most of this stuff works you
didn't mean to eliminate
somebody else's paper you were just
clicking on some buttons well that that
could be a case of ignorance right you
might not be responsible for what I'm
doing in that case what else he says or
is that to what end you you have a
different thing in mind how you're doing
he has the example once again of
somebody who doesn't understand their
own strength they hit somebody else they
don't realize they're going to kill them
when do people end up in in this sort of
ignorance rather certain things that
tend to make us lose sight of of things
I mean there are cases when we just
don't know these sort of things with
other characteristic conditions
all your tubes you be on of course that
have been drunk because they're all you
know 18 19 or so like that right but
let's just assume that any of you would
ever drank it moderately what happens to
people when they get drunk yeah you lose
judgment yeah you lose judgment which
means you become ignorant of some of the
facts of cases if you drink enough you
will become a current to pretty much
everything except for your immediate
surroundings and sometimes even whether
it up is down where you are you could
actually drink enough to become ignorant
of who you are what happens to people
sometimes are you have to drink an awful
lot I think too for that sort of thing
to happen but there are there's a state
of ignorance that comes from drinking or
we can think about any other drug right
somebody takes a hallucinogenic and now
I had a friend for instance who who was
a hippie and what would got her off of
the acid which he took for quite a while
was that she had a bambusa nation
werewolves were coming out of the walls
to eat her and it went on for hours and
that that cure she never took acid again
after that now those bowls weren't real
all right let's say one of those Bulls
was actually her friend and she thought
she was fighting a wolf when she hit her
friend with the lamb or the paper waiter
pick whatever poker you know she would
be ignorant what about when we get angry
do we do we become ignorant of things
when we get angry yeah like the fact
that we actually love the person that
we're fighting we traded up that don't
we pretty easily so these can be things
that what if you would be out here what
if you're the kind of person that thinks
that wrong things are actually the right
thing to do
and like doing could that be a chance
what do you think does that feel the
same to you though as the sort of
ignorance like I just didn't realize
that the stick was pointed when I'd like
home with that person with it I was just
screwing around and I actually we had
them through that seemed to be the same
kind of ignorance I didn't realize that
that you know it's really wrong to kill
people because I actually like doing
that sort of thing and I'm cool person
does that seem similar to I accidentally
poked up where is there seemed to be a
difference Aristotle says there are
certain kinds of ignorance that were
actually responsible for think about it
in terms of closets right you have any
action and the action can be done
because of ignorance but if you're
responsible for the state of ignorance
that you're in you are acting in the
ignorance but you're not acting just
because of ignorance so if you're drunk
who got you drunk most of the time yeah
yourself I mean you actually like raise
the beer the liquor or the wine it'd be
different I suppose if somebody else got
you drunk in the middle of the night you
didn't realize that they they pour the
liquor down your throat where they
injected you with heroin or you know
they're busy with the hallucinogenic
into your soda or something like that
then then it would be somebody else is
responsible right you're not you're not
accountable for that's where science or
let's say something goes wrong in your
brain you know they're in their cases
where people have a stroke or an
aneurysm or they get hit in the head
hard and things go wrong inside there
in a variety of different ways you know
it's not always things like losing
hearing or you know losing color vision
sometimes it's things like not being
able to recognize your family you know
which would make it very hard to be a
mother or a father would you be
responsible for that state of ignorance
know it would be something else that's
causing it if you have a bad character
so bad that you actually think wrong is
right you are ignorant but how did you
get that by doing bad things over and
over and over again making the wrong
decision so Aristotle would say in a
case like that if your replies is the
reason why you're ignorant that you
would actually be responsible for them
and then wouldn't get you off the hook
so now notice ignorance is sometimes a
reason why we're not responsible for our
actions but sometimes it isn't same
thing with compulsion you know they're
there could be some sort of there are
some things that can compel us but you
know realistically if I hold a gun to
any of your heads I'm guessing none of
you are like ex-military ex-police or
anything like that right all again
college freshmen so when woody of you
have ever done that sort of thing none
of you have like military training
something equivalent to that and we
prepare you for the danger somebody
holding a gun to your head right you
don't know okay so then I hold a gun to
your head and I tell you to go to the
ATM and take out all your money are you
responsible for that money being gone
with when your your say your spouse your
boyfriend girlfriend says yeah we're
looking at the accounts and there's
nothing in it said well somebody had a
gun to my head you would be you would be
doing the action all right and in a
certain recent sense you would be
responsible because you could have done
otherwise you could
taking a bullet in your head but who
wants a bullet in there other than you
know suicides that that's a pretty
strong means of compulsion I can make it
even worse I take your your family
member and I say if you don't do it I
say I'm going to kill them or torture
them or whatever Aristotle would say
that's where the compulsion can make an
action in voluntary now let's say it's
something like I still chocolate bars
because I really really really like the
taste of John Dawkins I'm a kleptomaniac
or you know has some sort of
psychological disorder and I recognize
that it's wrong I just like to taste the
chocolate so much you know and you know
how i could buy it but you know who can
buy enough chocolate I have to spend my
money on other things but I really need
that chocolate because I need the good
taste to them that seems like the more
that I eat more chocolate I am I
responsible for that yeah because the
most people have that sort of compulsion
all of you like chocolate right anybody
here who doesn't like chocolate all of
you really like chocolate right there's
probably some tasty you like better than
chocolate and willing to bet chocolate
if I gave you what are your top five
tasty but probably in the clip for most
of it it is for me does that mean that
that we're justified in saying because I
have a desire for chocolate
for my behavior the way advertisements
sometimes you have people doing what do
you think does that seem reasonable to
you Aristotle thing doesn't think that
it's reasonable either he says if
someone were to say that Pleasant and
Noble objects have a compelling power
forcing us from without and this is when
people do say right I had to have that I
was I was under the spell of an
attraction I couldn't help myself I
couldn't control myself forcing us from
without it could be chocolate it could
be a beautiful person it could be a
great business opportunity it could be a
chance to go backstage with with a band
than you really like even though that's
probably not a good idea this is sort of
a digression I actually had to when I
was not much older than you guys I
actually had to keep my sister from
touring with a thrash metal band like
the way that she looked and wanted to
take her on their US tour on the bus and
I knew what that meant so I you know and
I had a lot of kind of walk friends at
the time so we we persuaded to the
handset to send them to offer because it
would have been a very bad idea for her
to do but it would have been something
very attractive right why would she have
considered that well that that sounds
like a really fun thing to do there are
certain things Pleasant and Noble
objects that we feel almost have a
compelling power they draw it's really
our desire though our desire that's in
us that's drawing us to the object it's
not that the object just by itself
attracts us like a magnet it's that
there's something inside of us that we
don't control that we don't sometimes
even
full consciousness and that is what is
sort of in tune to that object if we
were going to say this then all the acts
would be compulsory those who act under
compulsion unwillingly act for that with
a pain that those who do extra their
pleasantness do them for pleasure so
like Arizona says it's absurd to make
external circumstances responsible and
not oneself as being easily caught by
such attractions so Aristotle's kind of
hardliners he would say if you are so
susceptible to chocolate that you will
do bad things in order to get chocolate
then you probably should stay away from
chocolate you should probably realize
you know what's going on and you know
you have a choice in that if you realize
what are some other things that are more
realistic what are whatever other things
that people desire that get them in
trouble bracket yeah I mean if you get
out of crap that's pretty much yeah
let's let's take some stuff that's a
little less Sixteen that have been crack
cocaine money yeah I mean if you use the
universe crackheads at least go out and
try to you know do things heroin is lay
around money yeah people desire money
what people do all sorts of bad things
to get money well people make the wrong
choices in order to get money is it is
it that the money is just attracting
them so much it's on their side if they
did that this is what movies are you
know what happens with me the bag of
money shows up on your doorstep what are
you going to do in order to keep it in
order to hold on to it
those are the sort of things that
Aristotle is talking about what else
money is a good one drugs you know
different sorts what else get people in
trouble that they do have some control
but they will often say it's a
compulsion I can't help I can't help
myself and as someone could trim it is
not at the start what about gambling
gambling it made you need like to write
because again the whole I know guys when
I was working as a security guard who
would get their their checks and in two
days the whole check was blown because I
go to casino lucky they were living off
at home with her mom's other words they
took out on the street what about sex
people under get in trouble over over
sexual relation relationships and they
said I was so attractive I couldn't help
myself I just had to do it what sort of
things resolved from that in fidelity's
right I mean it if your partner is
saying things like you know when you're
having conversations about who's
responsible and who's not and they're
saying things like I don't think that
people are actually responsible for
their own sexual behavior because we
just have these compulsions and we have
to follow them you probably don't want
to stay with that person right if you
got your current partner because they
cheated on somebody else to be with you
they claimed that they had an
irresistible attraction to you knock it
out because they probably will have an
irresistible attraction of some other
bodies as well right food can be you
know problem like this there's lots of
things that Aristotle talks about in
other places that could turn out to be
these sorts of problems right so now is
notice we've laid out sort of a theory
of responsibility
we've gotten a little bit into the
metaphysics of the human person there
are some things that are subtle things
that you are not responsible when you
sneeze of course if you give you if you
take stuff and then you sneeze you are
responsible for that right if you're
clapping because you're you've got a
sinus infection I got into your lungs
you're not responsible for that of
course if you got a sinus infection and
you didn't go to the doctor and it got
really bad and then you know got
pneumonia from it did you have any
control over whether you go to the
doctor and in this society if you
forgetting about third world societies
yeah you can go to the doctor so you
know there are some things where
compulsion could be caused by the things
that we choose to do remember what
Aristotle said about these of these
causes right it's important to look at
the chain of causality so let me ask you
as we end this as you guys get ready to
gear up for your midterms will actually
have a little bit early today so after
thinking about these things how many of
you can think of something that at the
beginning of class you thought people
were responsible for and now you're not
sure or vice versa something that you
thought people are responsible for and
now you think maybe they are but nobody
had a change of thought on that sort of
thing that's unfortunate that I haven't
done my job very well because the one of
the goals of this was to get you to
think more deeply about this and
sometimes our ways of looking at these
that we come in with party actually the
right way is part of the reason why we
present you with all these philosophers
and their theories is to try to get you
to not necessarily adopt their you
notice I didn't ask how many of you now
are risky chilean to accept Aristotle's
view I just wanted you to actually sort
of think maybe it could be this way
maybe I need to have some doubts about
this so that's where we'll leave on I'll
see all of you on Wednesday I've got
your exams ready for you probably won't
take the whole class session